[موسيقى]
مرحبًا
يا
[موسيقى]
مثير للإعجاب جدًا
يبدو وكأنه يتحرك بسهولة ،
فهناك
ثلاجة
وأجواء أحبه عندما تكون
[الموسيقى]
هناك شيء مختلف حول مكان وجود
هذا الهواء في الأرجنتين
أستطيع أن أشعر أنه يمكنني أن أراه ،
على سبيل المثال ، محطة السكك الحديدية هذه التي تم
ترميمها بشكل جميل والمحافظة عليها بشكل جميل
من حقبة مختلفة
جيدًا ، ما هو جوهر
الاختلاف هو أنه بسبب
ماضي المهاجرين في الغالب من أوروبا
أو ربما يكون ذلك هو المسافة الجغرافية
للأرجنتين.  في النصف الجنوبي من
الكرة الأرضية ،
مهما كان الاختلاف الذي لا أعتقد أنه
مهم ،
فإنه يستدعي
اكتشاف الاختلاف الذي
يمكن اكتشافه في أشكال بوينوس airs بأشكال عديدة ، لكنني أعتقد أنه
لا يوجد شيء يتحدث عن
الإحساس المثير بالحيوية والمرح بالمكان
وهو وطني  ارقص
على رقصة التانغو ، دعنا نرجع للخلف مع رقبتك
اليمنى
يمكن تشكيلها في أي مكان
وإغلاقها على الأقل في عالم Horatio's Goodoys
حيث يسير الرقص جنبًا إلى جنب مع
ذلك  دين آخر
كرة القدم
[موسيقى]
هل تعلم هل تعرف من هو
مارادونا
الذي تعرفه عندما نتحدث عن دييغو
علينا أن نقول أوه سان دييغو نعم ،
نسيت من تتحدث معه
تتحدث إلى بريطاني لا أعرف  أنا
أعرف اليد ، أنا آسف جدًا ، يد
الله ، من فضلك ، دعنا نتمسك برقصة التانغو
حيث قد نتفق على أن
هوراشيو قد أوصلني إلى لا بوكا
، الميناء الأصلي للمدينة ، حيث
وصلت موجات من المهاجرين الإيطاليين
في بداية القرن العشرين
هنا مكان  بدأ التانغو
أعتقد أن الناس بحاجة إلى شيء ما في
حياته في الفضاء الجديد ويبدأ الناس
في الرقص لأنهم يريدون الحصول على
شيء مع السيدات الذين تعرفهم ولكن
لا يمكنك الرقص مع السيدات منذ 120 عامًا ،
لذا عليك التدرب
مع الرجال مع رجل  أنت تعرف
الرجال فقط هنا ، نحن
نعم ، لأن السيدة ستكون
في هذا الوضع ، ماذا يعني هذا
يعني اليد اليمنى ،
نعم نعم ، وإلا فأنت
في دور السيدة ،
حسنًا ،
ها نحن
نتنهد ونغلقك فعلت ذلك
حق فعلت ذلك
أضف نساء وما بدأ كرقصة رجل فقير
أصبح إحساسًا بالحيوية في جميع أنحاء العالم
أكثر من foxtrot الذي أصبح أقل رسمية
من رقصة الفالس
تانجو في الأرجنتين ،
لذا فهو مثل أعذار رقصة التانغو ، فأنت لا
تكون وحيدًا
لتكون مع أشخاص ليكون لديهم أصدقاء
صديقات صديقات  كل شيء
لأنه رابط
إلى الرابط بين البشر
[الموسيقى]
لا يمكن تجاهل هذا الجذب الأساسي
في أجواء بوينوس في
غضون لحظات يجب أن تعطيني كارثة الرقص بالقدم اليسرى
بعض الخطوات الأساسية
[موسيقى]
هذا أمر صعب حقًا
ولكنه  مغنية ممتعة رائعة
برافو
رائعة
أعتقد أنه يجب أن يكون وقت الغداء